let's get the pads here for barkley
you're going to be putting these on okay
if you can figure out something
something i've never done before
you have the glove
blocker i honestly don't even know how
you put those pads on
okay don't i have to put the skates on
before i put the pads on i think we're
going to probably go without the skates
yeah yeah we know he's nervous
i don't think we need the pads
oh we'll get this no no it's all going
on okay but it's going to take 15
minutes how do you hold a stick with
these shots
there it is
well how do you hold it though
i don't know i was never the only
this way okay i got you now guys what do
you think of the form wait clearly chuck
never made our production meeting yeah
chuck that's like i'm holding the driver
okay now grab it i'll grab it hey rick
yes no no no no the
like this
yeah there you go
rick what's the five hole
what's the five hole he'll show you oh
no i hope he doesn't go too high on the
five hole i need a stick no so this is
just the beginning we're going to tape
this whole thing we're going to get you
stick
i need to know what the five hole is
that's it yeah so that's all you're
doing no yeah i got i got advice today
from daryn
that's the five hole he told me to
show you the five hole and then take it
away then take it away
you got to stretch out though but i
didn't know
i didn't know what the five hole was put
the stick in front of you between the
legs there you go
i i don't think he's gonna save one of
them really i don't think he's got one
for one save here yeah one second no
you're going against the great one bud
gretzky here we go rory you are right
the shooter just count for the record
yeah i'm gonna count them okay let's go
here we go
shot one oh
top cheese
oh that's your ear charles
buddy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah there we go
no no no no no no no
you got to stop one of these
oh
my goaltending coach panger sucks
chuck butterfly go down like this
butterfly on your knees
or hamstrings somebody's worth it come
on come on
[Applause]
we're gonna send you down on the miners
for two weeks you'll be back in two
weeks
and the phone never rings the